and all these things bottled up that I
never got to speak about well now
Savannah Chrisley's talking as her
parents Todd and Julie Chrisley begin
serving time behind bars I love you I
love you you are the greatest human
being I think I've ever met after after
her parents reported to prison on
Tuesday Savannah shared this pic of her
mom to Instagram vowing to Forever fight
for this smile the best way that I can
describe it is like grieving the loss of
parents who are still alive Todd and
Julie were found guilty of bank and tax
fraud last year what we will not do is
we will not break because God didn't
bring us this far to drop us off they
were sentenced to a combined 19 years in
prison though they apparently don't plan
on staying there for that long look any
family who faces a loved one going to
prison it's a very difficult challenge
that's true for this family
ET spoke with the Chrisley's attorney on
Wednesday he says the family's actually
feeling positive about the future they
know what the road ahead looks like and
they know they have an opportunity to
appeal their case that's what they're
doing and they're optimistic about those
results I just want to say to everyone
we thank you we thank you for your
continued prayers and your support
that's Julie on Savannah's unlocked
podcast recorded just days before she
surrendered herself to authorities
people don't always have your best
intentions
at heart but I have become stronger in
knowing that
I'm going to get through it that I may
have some bumpy roads ahead
that my kids may have some bumpy roads
ahead my husband but we're going to get
through it and like her Mom Savannah's
confident better days are coming I've
never seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith in the end the
truth will prevail may get harder before
it gets easier but we have faith but
until then she's putting some life plans
on pause until I know that they're gonna
be there yeah I can't get married I
can't have a kid and dad has told me
like when I start feeling bad for myself
dad was like it doesn't if I may not be
here in front of you he was like but I'm
still alive yeah I'm still fighting I'm
still you know you don't have to live a
day without speaking to me exactly